this taste is still happening
he's still running bro what's going on
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by daniel kaluya he's
an academy award-winning actor you know
from acclaimed performances in films
like black panther get out judas and the
black messiah and many more his latest
project though is the jordan peel
written and directed sci-fi horror film
note which is set to theaters on july
22nd daniel cluj welcome to the show wow
thanks for having me man what's going
through your head as you prepare to take
on the wings of death today winning
success victory
a little bit of fear
[Music]
two bites sure yeah we'll go two bites
already bro
i'm nervous yeah i mean i've got this
[Music]
what's going on i mean it's cool
i'll have the whole wing
there you go
see if you can keep it going
no
good job
[Music]
so in all my years of doing this show
this interview with you for nope is one
of the first times that i've actually
been dying to actually see the screener
but respect to everyone involved for
keeping it such a tight lip production
yeah do you think that there's anything
uniquely evocative about a horror film
like nope which is set often times with
the most chilling action happening
during daylight hours with the sun still
up yeah because um
you can see things when the sun's up
that's that's what's really been
interesting about this process is like
when it's dark you can't look up in the
sky and see what i mean i can't really
spoil it but
he found a way to bring fear into the
light essentially which i think was
pretty special
i'm easy man how you doing i'm doing
good i'm doing good so far i can hang
for at least a couple here just a couple
are you ready to move on to this next
one this is the adobo local island wing
sauce here in the two spot all right
cool let's do it i'm gonna do two i'm
gonna take two bats
i'll be cautious now
[Music]
black work
it's gonna be about four winners
i've seen many guests come in and that
first half you know just doing videos
you have to give yourself life you got
to guess yourself you got to gather
yourself is that that this
you right i know you bro you got to be
mentally prepared
so i read that you wrote your first play
inspired by the film good burger when
you were only nine years old but i'm
actually more interested in this deep
cut from holly hughes who said that you
wrote a great piece about a pair of
grime artists when you're just a
teenager
what do you recall about that time at
the heat and light youth company in
hempstead theater you're like nardvar
you mentioned holly hughes
grandpa it was about it's called real it
was called real
i was i just fascinated about graham
and at that time because grandma's
peaking then
and then um and i just wanted to have
like find a way to marry grime and
theater
um during that time so yeah man that was
a i haven't haven't thought about that
play in ages so yeah
which was a bigger thrill for you
winning a bafta or getting name checked
by storms e4 winning about
the stills you name check was pretty
cause i was watching it i was like i'd
watch like i like watching music
performances that's like one of my
things so i was in the house watching
the brits
and it was like they were like oh yeah
like oh storms is going to be at the end
i'm not saying i'll have to watch all of
this to watch the end like so get to the
end and i'm watching it and he's like in
the rain and he's going and i'm like oh
he's doing a freestyle freestyle and i
heard my name and i just fell out the
chair fell out the chair i was by myself
fell out of the chair and my phone went
crazy and i was like yeah that was that
was epic because that you can't buy that
right you can't you just
that was epic that's always been a dream
you want to be like name checked by
rappers and that's cool man i'm saying
so they got strangely for that jump in
there's colleen all right
starts but it starts bubbling now in it
it's a bubble now
we're bubbling but still going in
still going in come on mom
nice wings though where'd you get wings
from
you know what these are amazing wings
victoria where we get these ones from
just wing it just wing it what's that
just wing it it's a you know there's not
many places in los angeles that have
wings available for delivery at 9 00 a.m
but they kind of just fall off the bone
it's good it's really nice it's really
succulent really strong like
yeah
big up just swinging it man
so since watching widows one of the
scenes that really sticks with me is the
one of you and the gymnasium with the
camera doing 360 degree loops around you
and the characters played by sir michael
rocks and chuck english of the cool kids
what would you say distinguishes steve
mcqueen as a director because i
understand that that approach the idea
to do the loops wasn't even decided on
until the day of the shoot
i think he's like i remember he even
spoke about it he wanted it to feel like
a a vinyl
record that's going round and round and
round and round and round he's probably
the only one other person has said
something about my acting and i feel
like oh yeah you're accurate and then
that it was that day he described it he
came up to me was like
you're weird i'm like yeah i am thank
you
like you're weird actor yeah i'm really
weird like it's like and he just he just
was really um
even in that scene he was like he was
doing a scene he was like intimidate
them without touching them
but he would leave the figuring out to
you you know but he knows how to talk to
people and
very intuitive very intuitive what role
did beanie siegel play as a creative
influence on your character in that film
yeah to say this out
guys beanie seagull yeah
that scene you like that one so when he
said that yeah i love that one brother i
tell you like nardvar like like i don't
know if i'm saying it right but hey
um beanie siegel so when i was younger i
was obsessed with worldstarhiphop.com
and there was a bit when beanie siegel
was just on his shoulder while bd crack
was rapping and just looking at him
while he's on his shoulder and kind of
looking at him but he's not looking at
the camera just looking at really crap
looking at petey crack and then like
peter crafts trying to rap and i always
remembered how awkward that was and how
i think that's how i kind of act i just
i take stuff in and i like looking at
life and real life moments and go how do
you
translate that into a film language like
actually get reality so then like when
he said
intimidate him without touching him it
just came it just popped in like me
watching it 16 years old when he
disrespects your personal space then
what else can you disrespect but yeah
beanie seagull inspired inspired me to
that petey crouch shout out petey crap
and beanie still
my guys was at state property
[Music]
all right cool it's nice fun
so far so good
easy money
easy money
[Music]
you're about to while out though
i understand the demand on your vocal
cords was particularly intense for your
oscar award winning performance as fred
hampton and judas and the black messiah
yeah did you learn anything valuable
about breath control or projection
studying alongside a opera teacher for
that film um
and i've learned it on a couple plays
but i do it for the plays and then i
forget about it because i'm not trained
i'm kind of self-taught in that so like
it's just to engage with your diaphragm
like really engages your diaphragm but
then when i get emotional or i get in
the moment i lose it but sometimes like
you won't be aware that you're doing
that so then you know like all right
cool i wasted a bullet on that my
throat's gonna be
when i did lose my voice in the tail end
of the day
i was able to still convey
what i wanted to convey for the crowd
without actually having to speak at all
i mean and you have to tap in it taught
me how to tap into that at the same time
but
so yeah that was a it's a big learning
curve for me and my voice was like an
accelerated drama school essentially
how you feeling after four i'm feeling
good bro how you feeling uh you're
looking good i'm feeling good we're in
this together on the climb on the way up
are you ready to move to the halfway
point already i am mike yes the seventh
reaper right in the five spot all right
cool we'll be doing this
yeah hold on
i took more than i was supposed to on
that one so i'm gonna take that one back
all the skin from the back
[Music]
hey my ears started to sweat
why is my ears sweating my ears have
never sweated before what's going on
how can i feel my ears there will be a
lot of firsts there will be a lot of
first no i'm gonna do two bites because
i don't want anyone to say
there we go
so when we had idris alba on the show he
gave me a crash course in cockney
rhyming slang and then charlie sloth
taught me all about churchill birds it's
legend choice from from my aerial shout
out yeah yeah what does it mean when
someone from the uk says rock it kind of
sounds like when an american says bet
but i can't quite figure it out raw raw
raw it's like
i just use it as well like raw like that
happened bro right like wow like it's a
mini wow a mini wow wow
wow
do you have a favorite british phrase
for getting drunk last time i was in
london we were at a pub and my friend's
cousin kept talking about being goosed
goosed all right
waved i like waved
and that waved how would you use it in a
sentence
i got waved
wait
wait ocean saying it was rocky
and it was like
yeah waved that's that first one that
comes to mind
all right back half time
the sixth spot you're doing great by the
way man i'm built for this you are built
for this footage i tell people
so this next one
hot and saucy
collard and ghost
[Music]
that one's starting to dance
my eyebrow's starting to sweat now
joining the ears joining the ears yeah
it's the right eyebrow on the left ear
they're doing the whole dance for
themselves
so i'm interested in what i've heard you
describe as accessible excellence with
the goal of making films for the friends
that you grew up with yeah as an actor
how do you think about the balance
between a film's high-minded thesis and
then just the basic north star of
entertaining people first and foremost
it's like
i said bob marley you wanna you wanna
say something so a baby can understand
it
you know and that's i think it's a
symptom of understanding if you say it
simply
so that's my thing it's like oh it's all
good knowing all this stuff but can you
translate it i'm gonna say i'm gonna say
it because i always
say it's saying it's harsh yeah and they
described it perfectly yeah
and it's like axis yeah boom bats yeah
and they said the top here is simple
and bought here is complicated we're
actually talking about two albums i'm
gonna say whose albums it was
here is
normal and here is special right
and the beauty spot is here top rap
simple special
i was actually blowing my mind and said
yeah that's why michael jackson's a
genius i was like why because she said
abc as easy as one two three oh like bob
marley says no woman no cry like it's
like say it simply and so that i want to
translate that into cinema and as you
have to understand so much and
understand the person you're speaking to
in order to do that if the film don't
work that's left you know i'm saying but
at least i i know they know that i care
and i will
look at the details and they go oh no i
didn't work but this is that you know so
that's how i see cinema i see the
audience i want them to like have a good
time because it's it's not cheap i mean
going to the cinema so i'd want that
yeah
accessible excellence it's a movement
[Music]
the font's terrifying i'm into fonts but
the font's terrifying what like how do
you pitch that in a sales meeting
you say simple
special first
let
good though
they're crushing those wings we're
probably approaching kind of the
that went into my nose though
nose eyebrows chicken
chill chill relax it's all good
it's all good my back of my neck is
sweating though and i don't know why
it's sweating like everybody's coming to
the party yeah eyebrows
so aspiring actors create all different
types of strategies when it comes to
fueling their quest for stardom but
yours i understand is purely statistical
saying i have to get one job out of
three how did you come up with that math
and i understand that your production
company even 59 percent is steeped in a
real statistical measure measure of
success in sports yeah wanna freak i was
cocky
and then 59 percent
that's based off moneyball
because i'm obsessing about that film
i'm pissed about that book and that's
the win rate of that team
that one was 59
and then like then i like i can't i'm
going to say this but say one of my
favorite managers is a man united
manager i'm an arsenal guy it's um alex
ferguson sir ferguson got put some
respect on his name and that
how he responds to losses was always
what spoke to me like he used the loss
as a asset
all right who i [ __ ] up there well i'm
gonna learn all right cool
oh yeah this that's what happened this
is that okay i've gotta make changes
it's the same principle as i did back in
the day is that one out of three if
i get if i don't get free i like cool
i've got to look at myself i've got to
study i've got
get myself up and that's an opportunity
to
to study up to kind of get your skills
and craft to a certain level so then
that you can sustain the level you're
trying to reach you feel me that you're
gonna reach
the bomb
it's called beyond insanity brother
sounds like the worst
circuit worst hit circuit ever oh well
it's all bad and more
let me tell you before we mucus is mucus
wants to come out
my mucus is coming
hey
i'll be honest
[Music]
proper built for this but the building
isn't shaking
hey
we are awake
well but you're going back in cool smoke
i'm built for this there we go
no we don't we don't fold
it up fold sometimes to my stupidity but
hey wow
you're standing this one
looking at right in the face
yeah
i'm here my dad respect respect
yeah that's a bible
so i know you have family in chicago you
shot widows in the windy city and
likewise have controversial takes on
pizza are you thumbs up or thumbs down
on chicago style deep dish
this taste is still happening
it's still running bro what's going on
hey
i'm listening
pizza's just like
pizza's an open sandwich if you really
look here it's like cheese
but my tongue is going nuts
it's like cheese they just grill the
cheese put some bread on it cook the
bread tomorrow
it's not like
it's an open sandwich
not its own genre over here you know
what is i realized why i felt that way
i had a friend yeah
my friend used to work at pizza he used
to do the friday night shift so i had to
go to pizza hut to clear up with him
so that i can so we can go out early
this chicken is going nuts in my mouth
hey to relax i'm trying to talk
blood
i got new tears bro what's going on
careful careful around your eyes too
yeah yeah [ __ ] you didn't do anything no
no no no no i'm cool just be careful
just be careful
yeah no no he's got pizza so then i used
to see pizzas on a different level i see
a backroom staff and i used to like
basically work there but not get paid
and then like and then i just was like
no i'm not convinced on pizzas it's over
i understand that you had to shed a lot
of weight for your role as a boxer and
sucker punch and your mom was not too
happy about it because you couldn't eat
her food anymore yeah what was the mama
kahluya dish that you missed the most
when you're shedding weight oxtail
[ __ ] sells great helps that's crazy it's
fantastic
five star i'd strongly advise you to try
it well i would love to i would love to
come come to london i'll get you some
other stuff
all right we're still on good terms even
after you just yeah i'll give you a
proper tupperware you have to take a
tupperware a tupperware that's been
washed a couple times not a new one know
i mean give it a whole shabow
[Music]
psycho
what is going on
[Music]
what's happening bro
i know i know i know but the good news
is we're almost to the end
that's just crazy
bro
so once would you say that my favorite
thing is to find an artist before they
have a wikipedia page what would you say
distinguishes a fan who recognizes you
from get out versus someone who knows
you as parking pa toyo
you are hilarious
you are not va not boy that's you bro um
that's my mom's favorite character i've
ever played when people do that when say
that i'm like what d
on the topic of british comedies did you
have a lasting memory working alongside
rowan atkinson the master of physical
comedy himself
for johnny english reborn johnny was
reborn he is like
never seen anyone work hard no i have
but he's like he works so hard we did 25
takes of every shot he worked so hard
he's so detailed he's like methodical
about every single thing he does just
being 21 and being next to him for that
many months i learned so much from him
but yeah like i'm in tears bro
well that is a lovely segue
to the tenth and final wing yeah
[Music]
my ego says yes come on let's do it bro
do i win the press
the glory of uh
victoria do we have any t-shirts
maybe a mug or something so a little dab
yeah yeah little dab
[Music]
one bite
[Music]
two bites come on man never got built
for this
[Laughter]
[Music]
there's water
yeah defeated all the wings just to get
blindsided by the water over there
but the good news is we're about to roll
credits on our bizarro world lunch with
the wings of death today and jordan
peele he tells this story about how you
secured your role and get out yeah by
nailing the sunken place scene five
takes five takes in a row where you had
a tear fall at the exact same time in
each take
so under these bizarre circumstances i'm
curious from your perspective
what is the key to crying on camera and
do you think that hot sauce could be a
performance enhancer for an actor
yes
i can very see now
if you need tears don't use
the um menthol
use psycho whatsoever
you tap into it's like stanislavski
sometimes you do emotional memory
sometimes for me it's color
but it's a mad situation i remember the
color i was wearing
the color would trigger me
now go straight into that space band go
so i do that
a lot of times it's like what else
you're going to do if you feel for the
character and you feel for the other
person you're really present in the
scene but a b c you know that's c
so it's not a performance it's just a um
it's an actuality it's just like oh abc
that's the end of the sentence that's a
full stop
so i kind of stay in that but when you
have to do half things
[Music]
when you have to do half steps you have
to be in the middle of it that's when
it's quite difficult that's when you
have like assistance that's when hot
sauce could come in
well i'll tell you one thing daniel
claudia there's not a dry eye in the
house after that performance today with
the wings of death and now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you this camera this camera
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life oh yeah i got
to say something to someone because
someone introduced me to hot ones hey
ben schiffer
we made it
i told you i do this my guy you told me
to not text you beforehand so you're
going to see this peggy please keep that
in mind that's my guy we're keeping it
um but hey ben and then oh yeah man
watch nope um what else do you want me
to say yeah like
take care of yourself man uh like like
cream your ankles like the back of your
ankles cream that like attend to
yourself cream your feet
it's important don't try to say you've
got to do so certain things like dude
like do it in the dark do it in private
hey just do the right thing in private
that's what mine's saying hey this is
delirious this thing makes me delirious
i don't even care like i don't care
[Applause]
great job
you're a great interviewer you're one of
the best in the game you proper care
it's great well i love that you know i
do you know
i think it's only right you know if
we're going to have you jump through
this hoop we got to jump through a
couple of ourselves yeah but you don't
have to you don't have to care as much
as you do you do you really do it's
really amazing oh like even watching
your interviews is proper so thank you
for that
hey that's mud
hey what's going on hot ones fans thank
you so much for watching today's episode
and i have an announcement to make the
first ever hot sauce for kids hot ones
junior it just got a little bit hotter
you know the green say hello to our
brand new hot sauce the yellow
a super mild hot sauce with sweet
tropical heat from mango pineapple and
scotch bonnet pepper
the yellow it's ready to party with
tacos nuggies heck even ice cream to get
your hands on the newest hot ones junior
sauce visit heatness.com.com.com
to pick up the yellow
you